you're watching screen junkie central
this episode is brought to you by mafia
3 family because who you die for and
e-signal Rudnick and you guys what's
going on street junkie central live in
San Diego and I just do one thing when I
say screen junkies you say central it's
screen junkies yeah
energy energy are you feeling it you
having a good con and I am I'm just
getting tired so Oh big experience this
con we've been doing so much fun stuff
I'm even losing my voice I know you're
gonna have to take you to the hospital I
know but it's LeWitt's bad guys are just
energizing me yes thank you for being
here I'm so excited
Wow we got a cool panel coming up right
now I'm so excited oh boy oh boy we have
some of the folks behind the show
American Dad make some noise guys yeah
Eddie
should we introduce our special guest
let's do it let's do it all right we
have a writer and creator the show Matt
Weitzman oh nice RJ nice the voice of
Steve Scott Grimes don't do it anywhere
you want and the voice of Francine Wendy
Shaw
and the voice of Haley Rachael
MacFarlane awesome thank you so much
guys for being here very exciting we
also have a one of also my writer
producer is a Jordan Bloom come on
Jordan Jordan blow and thank you for
being here brother so you guys must have
done comic-con a bunch of times how many
cons are you is this a regular you're on
first cloud the very first color first
time it's like 13 in a row well we've
only done with a server we're starting
our 12 season so I think we didn't do
the first year so there's our 11th Khan
Wow
that's yeah no it's insane um so uh does
it do you still enjoy it is it crazy oh
this is crazy cuz I was not expecting
this seriously nice like we came through
like a bee here weird Ali to you guys
yes we're out they let us off the bus
and suddenly here we are on the stage so
this is very exciting
awesome awesome um do you guys have any
like crazy comic-con stories or anything
you're like oh there was that one con or
oh that one time that we partied on a
boat with the cast of Game of Thrones or
something
God just that was the story I was gonna
tell right here that exact one they
always think I'm Danny Bonaduce and that
bothers me and it doesn't bother me
because I don't like Danny Bonaduce
Bosman because they didn't realize it
maybe Danny Bonaduce is like sixty now
right right but you sing as well as
Danny Bundy I don't thinks Danny buck
did you did his own singing and that
other dude do you I know you know I
think we need to break it I do now
alright so uh let's uh let's talk a
little bit so glad we're practicing you
you know what you could easily do some
Danny Bonaduce cosplay oh I could I'm
doing it right now
um just punch me in the face
yeah so people out there people know
this people know that he got a big video
who he is oh yeah uh yeah I'm gonna make
some noise if you know Danny Bonaduce
okay
thank you thank you guys Danny Bonaduce
nice nice not too deep a cut for our
audience um so let's talk about
obviously American Dad great show so the
world has changed of American Dad it
started in the early mid-2000s when Bush
was in office and there were a lot it's
you know there was a lot of politics
going on in the show can you talk about
how being on the show for 12 seasons
being on the air how the world of
American Dad has changed well I mean
I've said this in the past that we began
as a political show there was a you know
Seth is a very political person and
there was a little bit of a angst and
foreboding to what the world was going
to bring with Bush being in office
luckily that none of that transpired but
we ended up having a show that was very
much about politics and then we found
out that a lot of those jokes weren't
playing long-term so we became much more
of a family show with a you know
conservative father and left-wing
daughter and so that kind of plays out
in the show on a regular basis but less
so about you know who was Ruth Bader
Ginsburg and you know and people who are
very known politically for the moment
and then gone so but it's what's weird
is that you know we're back into a world
where politics is now right back in the
forefront so but because I showed last
you know it takes over a year to create
each episode
chances are we still will not have too
many you know current episodes about
Trump or Clinton because it's still a
difficult thing to kind of go off in a
year even if you don't write it Stan and
I are voting for Trump well I was going
to ask like is it are you don't you want
to write it now I mean is that is it -
oh you have too big of a target right
now - not well by the time we even
started it it would be over and done
within a year fair I think he's a Roger
persona anyway like I don't think he's a
real
yeah probably so um yeah but I mean it's
a lot of it's it's the show still that's
how the show is kind of evolved in the
last 12 years and you know probably for
the show's betterment because you know
like I said politics is kind of we'd
like to do these evergreen stories that
are more about family and aliens oh
absolutely
so um how did that change your writing
process as far as developing characters
and stories when you made that shift
well I think that because we had a do
how to find a different slant that's
when our show got weirder and better
yeah we'd ended up doing a little bit
more you know off-the-beaten-path
moments whether it be the golden turd or
little weird um you know offshoots of
you know getting away from the story but
just jumping right back in doing it just
doing just being cool weirder which is
you know much easier for me to be for
sure I don't know why past the golden
turd here um explain to our audience for
those who are uninitiated or remind them
what the golden turd is because it's
really just this unique out-of-the-box
funny thing that gives rigor so I don't
we were all up very late one night early
on in the first season I believe and
drinking water just drinking water and
water and juice and we decided that
Roger basically happens is Roger has
gone to Taco King and ended up taking a
dump on the side of the road but turns
out that this dump is a valuable
all-consuming object of lust and evil
that the whole world wants and so
suddenly our very comedic or show
suddenly goes into letterbox form and
becomes a very dark noir drama where
there's not a joke for the next you know
two to three minutes and it becomes a
very you know weird world and it's no
local people are hurting each other it's
still people fighting over a turd right
yes exactly true it's going to hold
golden vulture turn and
we are actually going to complete we
stopped for a while and we're going to
continue it now this last season we
started up again and we're gonna do how
many times does the golden turd like
rear its head bad for some the firt well
we've done this will be our fourth or
fifth golden Terry installment Wow and
the scope gets I think a lot bigger with
this one it kind of comes up to the the
Pope is involved it good it gets the top
the turd gets the top right you're
better right it's yeah it's it's a it's
a high-class turd so it's the Pope gets
involved so it's like The Da Vinci turd
there's some little bears around the
turd yeah we thought you you knew what
the turd was but it's it's opening up
let's say maybe a possible movie in the
future I don't know so are we breaking
Comic Con exclusives there's going to be
a golden turd feature turd awakens you
heard it here first
I never may not come to be uh yeah I'm
curious just from the move to TBS like
has that and that's for all of you like
has that allowed you to be even crazier
in a way at all oh yeah and the actors
of you all have you noticed anything
yeah we get to say we get to say you
know what's the rule two shits in a
douche bag yep two shits in an episode
up yeah yeah yeah that's great I know no
we've really made progress and it's kind
of exciting when you get the script and
you find out that you got the for
the week - I've got like I've gotten a
couple shits from you thanks you're on
applause for two shits in a douche bag
do you always make sure to use them but
all three um you know it's not necessary
but you know I I kind of feel you know a
little dirty if I don't so you don't
want to be wasteful right exactly
I mean all those years and blocks where
we couldn't all those years at Fox where
you couldn't see the side of a boob and
we couldn't show cartoon butts we're now
making it up for in spades so it's nice
um so you guys I mean that's been an
amazing run and there's been so many
great stories I'd love to hear from each
of our voice actors what is a memorable
moment or what's one of your favorite
episodes that you've been a part of oh
God you can only pick down really um
mine would be when Steve got pregnant
and yeah I'm amalgamating two episodes
cuz there was also an episode where
Steve had sex with Roger but Roger was
in some avatar right with a fake vagina
um but he didn't get pregnant from
Rogers fake vagina right no no not that
was actually snot who had sex okay Roger
yeah yes when Steve got pregnant cuz
I've really kind of got to live Matt
Scott Grimes got to live through that a
little bit you know experience that you
became a little bit more tense I sure do
understand I sure did
Wow no I'm beautiful I've been trying to
push we're trying to figure out how to
bring that child back yeah that coz
Roger kind of gave birth to a child that
we haven't seen in 10 years and you know
one day maybe we'll find out what
happened to that little snuggle he'll be
in the golden turd movie that's an
exclusive narrative so that's a that's a
really unexpected surprising thing are
there any other something surprising
that has happened to your character over
the years or an evolution that you
didn't expect there was an episode where
uh it turns out that Francine fell down
a well as a child I don't know if all of
you remember that it was a real life
happening and help me out with this I
mean we could ask these questions I
always feel like it's like what cramming
for a test like yeah she comes back and
they're gonna relive or they want to
know what she's done with her life and
she's all nervous that she hasn't done
anything memorable with her life so was
that the I might be mixing them up is
that what I know when what is that what
she finds the giant squid with that no
that was not the same episode why do you
think that it is um no Francie has been
searching for purpose I think since the
beginning yeah right uh that was when
there was some big thing that been a lot
of seasons ribbony ya know we're at the
end of this next season we'll have two
hundred and
56 episodes or so I'm so curious up
because we actually we just talked to
the guys from Family Guy like do you
ever feel it do you ever worry of
repeating yourself like they were
talking about that like had that you is
there do you notice that where you're
like every I forget if we have if we
don't forget repeat ourselves I feel
again bad about ourselves yeah no no I I
mean there's always moments where you're
thinking you know we have to change this
I mean you end up mixing up characters
oh because you do that means Stannis can
only get frustrated with a son so many
times we tell we've told that story a
number of times and we try to you know
mix it up a little bit and find
different elements within that but you
can't you kind of can't help yourself
because we are a family show and unless
you know Haley has a baby or something
like that which there she's gonna try to
do next season then you know unless
we're adding more elements into the show
then you can't help but do a degree of
repeating yourself but we try to do it
as little as possible
luckily Roger you know because he's
created because he opens up so many
doors with being so many different
personas helps to kind of differentiate
every episode but you know I I feel I'm
kind of rambling right now but yeah and
at the same time I think that you can't
you panic yeah quite help but doing that
a little bit but we always try to make
it as unique a process and get to a
different result in the end every time
don't worry if you do repeat yourself
they remind you on Twitter that's why I
don't you have a traitor moment what's
your America Dada moment for you um I
think I can it's so hard to remember the
names of the episodes but I think it was
was it bollocks to Stan was that the one
where Hayley first shacks up with the
with look yeah yeah okay of a turning
point when when uh uh Patrick Stewart
singing I love little girls yeah we had
a question about Patrick Stewart
actually if you guys seen green room
have not I am NOT these really he's
really mean and he's ever terrifying is
that I'm just curious if you did is he's
so silly and on the show yeah no that's
his real person yeah terrifying I mean
it's fun to see a very sad one on the
show no he's one of the these super
charming and and yeah what is that like
working with him I mean it's very
intimidating but card I mean ya know
it's and Professor X so I'm sorry geek
out every time yeah I mean recently and
I probably should say this moisture see
well he took when he records he's
usually on the phone you hear him on the
speakers cuz he was wherever he is and
we were recording which is happened be
in the booth and he was in New Orleans
am I even allowed to say that yeah right
yeah and he was he said and we said oh
what are you doing in New Orleans and he
says I'm doing the noob yes okay good so
he says I'm doing the new Wolverine
movie and then we said Oh how's it going
he's like I'm not even allowed to I
shouldn't have even told you that and I
was like I was just a big liar you were
gonna tell us anyway yeah that's awesome
up cuz it's just us we're right lead us
we're not dreaming hey Scott I wanted to
ask I heard through the grapevine that
you've you went through one of your
toughest challenges as an actor this
past season playing r.kelly uh yeah man
this is so we you know guys know we've
done a lot of musical episodes yeah
which I love but they they wrote this
you know I never heard the song it's
like it's trapped in the trans in the
closet which is like this ever big
series yeah so we did we did so it's
like a wrap off like a wrap opera yeah
and we did six so Steve's trapped in a
it already aired but Steve trapped in a
locker and it's but what made it
difficult wasn't just the singing it was
every character that Steve is describing
he has to do the voice his version of it
so he's like in principal Lewis came in
the doors like variables uh tried to do
his voice I do snots wiser to that and
with the kind of that song is like Steve
47 dog is like just talking like yeah so
what he'll tell you I flaked canceled
pretended I was sick for two months yeah
cuz for summer here's what you shouldn't
do never have the guy that did the demo
be better than you are so they sent me
this thing this the guy that wrote at
ASA Taccone they said to tell ya is so
good as part of lonely on that I was
like how am I gonna go in and be better
so I kept cancelling and being like no
and he finally the only time you and I
ever argue cuz you're like get you're
gonna ask
in here dude we have to do this we have
a deadline I can be very me and I went
in and it was tough but I'm glad we did
it and I but I memorized it for some
weird reason like I could do it on
Broadway and like no dude just weeks
right there right now in if you want I
know the first one I know the first one
I remember it 347 in the afternoon I
should be doing my homework inside my
own room but bad luck got me all messed
up I'm in the locker room and now I'm
stuck see I'm a goner now yeah oh yeah
yes umm yeah that that's beautiful
see I was walking stuff like you are
ready for Broadway it feels like it man
uh Rachel uh I know uh you're you're a
wonderful singer yourself oh god I don't
want to follow that oh god of all let me
ask you this cuz um you you have a great
voice thank you yeah and you're kind of
from a musical family cuz Seth is a
song-and-dance okay
look but he's alright guys alright um
but uh like how did that like these
these siblings with all of this musical
talent how'd that come about like
growing up for you guys well doing
musicals together oh yeah seriously we
started we're about five our town had
this incredible program where I mean at
no joke I think I was six and he was
eight and we were doing Gilbert and
Sullivan nine money one kidding yeah I
think the first show I did was Pirates
of Penzance HMS pinafore the sorcerer
like seriously when we were little we
were learning these really complex
harmonies and and that's where we kind
of I feel like got our ears our parents
can sing too so it's in the genes
yeah but that's what it was that's
amazing I know Marty Holcomb in Kent
Connecticut she's the one that we can
give credit to she's got a great record
you guys should go Haley sings ah Austin
also an additional to miss Haley sings
and sit for now see what the future has
in store yeah all right fair enough very
cool so um and is there anything that we
should really look forward to anything
exciting on the horizon aside from just
lots of laughs um well we're gonna do
another Christmas episode we're gonna do
a Western um Klaus and Roger are gonna
sex yeah we're doing a Father's Day
episode we're doing we heard your
request tumbler yeah what else there's a
family American dad is gonna be part of
a video game that all of lots lots of
box properties like Family Guy and not
The Simpsons but everything else
Futurama king of the hill somebody else
they're doing like some big card
flipping game with with American Dad and
so that's something else it's apart from
the show I'm a board game or a game food
so yeah it's a that's an app phone
awesome app gap game um what else is
there like a dream crossover you guys
would want the cast like the show it's a
score in the cast like on the show like
Simpsons got you know we done did we do
a crossover with Simpsons no no this is
a Family Guy Amar'e showed up oh yeah
we've had like we've had guest spots
we've never at this is more like the
dream one for you of like I'd love to
have our characters with God
oh can Abby yes count Navi um as you
know people like want to do is that we
have seen a lot of Futurama talk I would
love to see that um part of me also
loves the idea of Archer because you
know they're both you know in that same
world that would be kind of a fun crazy
thing to kind of explore um at this
moment though you know we're just happy
you know keep on doing what we're doing
very cool well um you guys it has been
such a pleasure having you here having
us of course thank you for spending a
part of comic thank you guys so much
guys hey guys laws American Dad thanks
guys
thanks again to mafia 3 for sponsoring
this episode to watch our previous show
click the box to the left and to see
everything from screen junkie central
click the box to the right